Tonight, when the sun goes down, you're
going to flip a switch.
Light will flood the room and you won't
think twice about it.
But for 99.9% of human history, that
switch didn't exist.
When the sun set, the world went dark.
You couldn't even see your
own hand in front of your face.
But modern humans almost
never experienced this.
For over 300,000 years, every single one
of your ancestors spent
roughly half their life
in near total darkness.
They didn't even have
candles for most of that time.
Just the black sky, the stars, and
whatever fire they could keep alive.
So what did they
actually do for all those hours?
The answer changes everything we think we
know about sleep,
storytelling, and what it
means to be human.
Let's start with fire.
Because fire is the reason
any of this was possible.
The earliest solid evidence of humans
controlling fire comes from Wonderwerk
Cave in South Africa,
roughly one million years ago.
But fire didn't just keep people warm.
Fire completely
restructured the human day.
Before fire, our ancestors were like
every other primate.
When the sun went down, you climbed a
tree or found a sheltered
spot and you stayed still.
Moving at night meant becoming food.
Our eyes are terrible in the dark
compared to the predators that hunted us.
Leopards, hyenas, wolves, all of them
could see just fine.
Fire changed that equation overnight.
Literally.
A campfire creates a circle of safety
roughly 30 feet in diameter.
Inside that circle, predators won't come.
Outside that circle, you die.
This is not an exaggeration.
Anthropologists studying modern
hunter-gatherer groups have documented
that people who wander
away from the fire at night are
significantly more likely
to be killed by predators.
Even today.
But here's what's fascinating.
Fire didn't just protect humans at night.
It gave them something
they'd never had before.
Extra hours.
Think about this.
Before fire, the
useful day ended at sunset.
That's maybe 12 hours in
summer, as few as 8 in winter.
Fire suddenly added 2-4
usable hours to every single day.
But over thousands of generations, those
extra hours changed our species.
In 2014, anthropologist Polly Wiesner
published a study in the
Proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences.
She spent years recording conversations
among the
Jew-slash-Hwan-see-Bushman of the Kalahari
Desert, one of the last groups on Earth
still living something
close to the original human
lifestyle.
She found was striking.
During the day, about 80% of
conversations were practical.
Who's hunting where?
Which plants are ready?
Plants, logistics, economic negotiations.
Daytime talk was work.
But at night around the fire, the entire
character of conversation changed.
At night, 81% of
conversations were stories.
Tales of people in distant places.
Adventures.
Myths about the origins of the world.
Jokes that made the whole camp laugh.
Wiesner argued that fire-like
conversation is where
human culture was born.
The campfire was the original theater,
the original
classroom, the original church.
It's where humans learned to think beyond
the immediate present
and imagine things that
don't exist yet.
It's where we became us.
But the night wasn't just
about stories around the fire.
There was something else happening,
something that scientists only
rediscovered in the last
30 years.
You were not designed to sleep the way
you sleep right now.
In 2001, historian Roger E. Kirch
published a paper that
changed sleep science.
He had spent 16 years digging through
historical records, and he found
something nobody expected.
Over 500 references, spanning centuries,
prayer books from the
1400s, court records,
diaries, medical texts, letters from
ordinary people, even
passages in Homer's Odyssey.
All of them mentioned the same thing.
First sleep and second sleep.
Before the Industrial Age, people did not
sleep in one continuous block.
They went to bed shortly after sunset,
slept for about four hours, then woke up.
They stayed awake for one to two hours in
the middle of the night.
Then they went back to sleep for another
four hours until dawn.
This wasn't insomnia.
This was normal.
This was how every human on the planet
slept for thousands of years.
And what did people do during that
wakeful period in the
middle of the night?
Everything.
A 16th century French physician
recommended that couples conceive
children during this
window because they would do it better.
People visited neighbors, they
interpreted their dreams
while they were still fresh.
They wrote, "They simply lay in bed in
the dark and thought."
A doctor's manual from the 1500s advised
patients that the best
time to study and reflect
was during the "watch" as they called it.
The quiet hours between first and second
sleep when the mind was
calm and the world was still.
Now historians had been reading these
references for centuries, but
they kept translating "first
sleep" as something else.
Because they couldn't imagine that people
ever slept differently than we do now.
The assumption was so deep that
translators literally mistranslated
ancient Greek and medieval
Latin to make it fit
their modern experience.
But then science confirmed what history
had been saying all along.
In 1992, psychiatrist Thomas Ware at the
National Institute of
Mental Health ran an
experiment.
He took a group of volunteers and removed
all artificial light from their lives.
For one month, they experienced 14 hours
of darkness every night,
just like our ancestors
would have before fire
extended the evening.
Within weeks, every single participant
settled into the same pattern.
Four hours of sleep, one to three hours
of quiet wakefulness,
then four more hours of
sleep.
Nobody told them to do this.
Nobody suggested it.
Nobody's just did it, as if some ancient
program had been
waiting inside them the whole
time buried under
centuries of artificial light.
Ware measured their hormone levels during
the wakeful period and
found something remarkable.
The participants were in a state unlike
any normal waking state.
Their brains were producing elevated
levels of prolactin, the
same hormone released during
meditation and after orgasm.
They described feeling peaceful,
reflective, almost meditative.
It wasn't just a gap in sleep, it was its
own distinct state of consciousness.
One that most modern
humans have never experienced.
So what killed it?
The answer is simpler than you'd think.
Light.
In the 1600s, cities
began installing street lamps.
Paris was one of the first, under Louis
XIV, who wanted to reduce crime.
London followed.
The night, which had been a place of
danger and fear, slowly became navigable.
Then came cheaper candles.
Then gas lamps in the 1800s.
Then in 1879, Thomas Edison
commercialized the electric light bulb.
And within a generation, the night as
humans had known it for
300,000 years was gone.
And here's the part nobody talks about.
The word curfew comes
from the French couvre-feur.
It literally means "cover fire."
In medieval towns, a bell would ring at
night, signaling
everyone to cover or extinguish
their fires.
Not because of safety, because night was
supposed to be dark.
Night was when you slept.
Night was when you were vulnerable.
For most of history, being
out at night was suspicious.
In many medieval European cities, walking
outside after dark
without a lantern was literally
illegal.
Night belonged to
criminals and the supernatural.
People feared it in a way that's almost
impossible for us to understand today.
And then we conquered it.
We flooded it with light.
And we thought that was progress.
But here's what we lost.
Modern humans are exposed to artificial
light an average of seven
to eight hours after sunset.
This light, especially the blue light
from screens,
suppresses your body's production
of melatonin, the
hormone that regulates sleep.
Your body doesn't know the difference
between a light bulb and the sun.
When light hits your retina at 11 p.m.,
your brain interprets it as daytime.
It delays melatonin release.
It fragments your sleep.
It disrupts the circadian rhythm that
evolved over millions of years.
Researchers have found that people who go
camping for just one
week with no artificial
light at all have their melatonin cycles
reset by nearly two hours.
Their bodies start producing melatonin at
sunset instead of hours after it.
That's all it takes for 300,000 years of
programming to reassert itself.
We didn't just change when we sleep.
We eliminated an entire
phase of human consciousness.
That quiet reflective state between first
and second sleep, the
state that wears subjects
described as peaceful and meditative,
doesn't exist anymore for most people.
Instead, we have insomnia.
And we treat it like a disorder.
But what if it's not a disorder at all?
What if waking up at 2 a.m. and lying
there in the dark isn't
your body malfunctioning?
What if it's your body
remembering what it was built to do?
For 300,000 years, your ancestors spent
their nights in a
rhythm that modern science is
only beginning to understand.
They gathered around fires and told
stories that built civilizations.
They slept in two phases with a window of
quiet reflection in between.
They lived in darkness so complete that
the Milky Way wasn't
something you had to drive
to a national park to see.
It was just the sky.
And every night when they woke in the
dark between first and
second sleep, they lay there
in silence and thought about their lives,
their dreams, and the
world they would wake
up to in the morning.
We traded all of that for a light switch.
And most of us never
even knew it was gone.